one of the things i truly love is when a
radical ideologue gets confused and
doesn't even understand their own rancid
and disgusting talking points when i was
interviewed by jesse lee peterson in los
angeles a couple years ago i had trouble
not laughing when he would use terrible
debunked talking points but like he
would get them wrong about socialism and
other things so today i have a clip for
you that's really emblematic of a lot of
the covet disinformation that's floating
around republican congresswoman marjorie
taylor-green has been a big voice
against vaccine requirements against
masks in favor of various unproven
treatments for covid including
ivermectin she appeared on real
america's voice recently and hilariously
hilariously claimed that iver
won a nobel peace prize now there's two
layers of confusion here i won't explain
them yet let's look at the clip
ivermectin is a very good drug its
safetiness has been proven for decades
it even won a nobel peace prize
and it is absolutely irresponsible for
the biden administration uh the cdc uh
dr fauci and any of these doctors to be
advising people to to not prescribe it
isn't that just the best so two layers
of confusion here first of all
ivor mektin didn't win any nobel prize
and it definitely didn't win a nobel
peace prize there are two scientists
william campbell and satoshi amura
won a nobel prize in 2015
for discovering that a modified version
of ivermectin called avermectin could be
used
to treat infections caused
by roundworm parasites
nothing about a nobel peace prize nor
anything about ivermectin to treat covid
so consider the fallacious reasoning
here but this is the type of stuff these
right-wingers love they latch onto it
marjorie taylor green says or implies we
should be giving ivermectin for covid to
people because ivermectin won a nobel
peace prize and then you look at it ivor
mekden didn't win any prize especially
not a peace prize
two scientists
won a nobel prize
in medicine
for their discovery
that a different compound
based on ivermectin called avermectin
could be used
specifically for treating roundworm and
her view is
nobel peace prize
give it to people for covid but it just
gets repeated and repeated you hear it
once i vermecked and won a nobel peace
prize or nobel prize and suddenly you
hear the talking point everywhere and it
is everywhere it spreads uncontrollably
without any real investigation
the reason marjorie taylor green got in
trouble here by the way
is that nobel peace prize is like a
little too much so there's been more
fact checking like really a nobel peace
prize that doesn't that doesn't make
sense had she simply said nobel prize
this would almost certainly have
continued to spread without even more
fact checking of it done which
fortunately did take place sadly her
re-election is likely to happen
she's in a very red district back in
february march there were articles
saying oh she's got a tough uphill
battle big primary challenger
as far as i was able to find this
morning no serious republican primary
challenger um
two marjorie taylor green
and it is not looking good at all so we
may well be dealing with another two
years of marjorie taylor green and
another two years of exactly this type
of just humiliating humiliating nonsense
one of our sponsors is magic spoon
breakfast cereal sweet and tasty like
the cereals i loved as a kid but without
the sugar or the carbs every serving of
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar only
four net carbs 140 calories and packed
with 13 grams of protein perfect if
you're doing keto perfect if you're
doing low carb great if you're just
trying to reduce your excess sugar
intake and because it's packed with
protein it's great before or after a
workout magic spoon flavors include
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry and cinnamon they're bringing
back cookies and cream they're bringing
back maple waffle you can build your own
variety box and try them all magic spoon
is so confident in the product if you
don't love it as much as i do they will
refund your money no questions asked go
to magicspoon.com pacman the link is
underneath this video and you'll get
five dollars off when you use the promo
code pacman at checkout